[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the president of the united states the
honorable joseph
r biden jr and the vice president of the
united states
the honorable kamala harris have arrived
and are being greeted by the honorable
roy j
austin the third secretary of defense
general mark a milly chairman of detroit
chief
of staff miss karen durham aguilera
executive director army national
military cemetery
and major general omar j jones support
commanding general joint task force
national capital region
and the united states army military
district of washington
so
right
okay
give me
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
purple
so
so
oh
[Music]
ready
[Music]
okay
foreign breathe
foreign
[Music]
one
oh
[Music]
turn
so
freeze that
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
club
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
the wreath ceremony is now complete the
memorial day observance will begin
momentarily
please move to your seats
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
oh
so
ladies and gentlemen please stand for
the arrival of the official party and
remain standing for the invocation
and national anthem
[Music]
can we
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
accompanied by the secretary of defense
and the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen chaplain colonel
michael shellman
command chaplain joint task force
national capital region
and the military district of washington
please join me in prayer
almighty god who is the champion of
liberty
the champion of our freedoms and the god
who loves us with an everlasting love
today let us lift our hearts and prayers
in thanksgiving to you for those
patriots who paid the ultimate price
by giving their lives in full measure
for their country
with humble hearts may we never forget
their patriotism
and commitment as a nation we can never
be grateful enough
for the uncommon bravery of those sons
and daughters
who preserved our freedoms
lord thank you for the gift of liberty
and the blessings of freedom
that you have bestowed on our nation
the united states of america
let us never forget these heroic souls
our brothers and sisters of days gone by
some who never had the chance to grow
old let us thank them for their
sacrifice
as it continues to be our blessing in
their bravery
continues to be our reward
in your gracious name i pray amen
ladies and gentlemen please join
sergeant first class brendan curran
and the united states army band
pershing's own in the singing of our
national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please be seated
a memorial day for the over one million
americans who have given the last full
measured devotion
in service of their country since our
founding
more than 42 million americans have
stepped forward to
serve their country as soldiers sailors
airmen marines guardians
and coast guardsmen their story is of
course
one of courage selflessness and
commitment
this memorial day we honor their memory
and the values they upheld so that we
could
live in freedom from bunker hill to
gettysburg from the muse argonne iwo
jima
incheon the eidrang valley to the
korengal ramadi
and mosul their sacrifice is an example
for all of us
to never forget and to always honor
at the first official memorial day
ceremony held here at arlington in 1868
children who had been orphaned by the
civil war moved throughout the cemetery
laying spring flowers on the graves of
our soldiers
since that day 153 years ago
on this day in may we come together as
americans to mourn
but much more importantly than mourning
we come together as americans
to remember remember that we owe the
brave men and women who have lost their
lives in service to this nation
and remember too that behind every
fallen comrade is a family
a family whose sacrifices embody the
soul
that is america we reflect on the dreams
never realized
the pain of a parent who has lost a
child
the pain of a child who has lost their
parent
for every day is memorial day
for the families of our fallen but today
is also a day to celebrate their courage
and
how they lived and why they fought and
remember that they live for something
bigger than themselves
they fought for the values and
traditions of this nation
they fought for the belief that under
these colors
of red white and blue all of us
are americans and we hold these truths
to be self-evident
that all men and all women are created
equal
and each of our fallen knew
that freedom is worth fighting for
and each of them made a difference
so it is up to us the living
to leave these hallow grounds today and
recommit ourselves to the cause
for which they died but equally
important
to the cause for which they lived it is
our job
to live a life worthy of their sacrifice
so may god bless our fallen may god
bless the families of our fallen
and may god give us the strength to
defend the idea that is america
and ensure this nation shall not perish
from this earth
it is my privilege to introduce the
secretary of defense
a man i have known for a quarter of a
century
and whose leadership in the crucible of
battle
i have personally witnessed he's a
leader of
extraordinary integrity and it is my
pleasure to serve alongside him again
ladies and gentlemen it's my honor to
introduce the 28th
united states secretary of defense lloyd
j austin iii
mr president dr biden
madam vice president mr imhoff
general milley distinguished guests
service members
gold star family members my fellow
veterans
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
joining us on this solemn day
in this solemn place we come together to
remember
and to renew our sense of common purpose
and to reach out to those who have long
mourned
and to those who newly grieve
mr president and thinking about joining
you here today i reflected on a meeting
i held a few days ago
with some of our gold star and surviving
families
one of them was shannon slutman the wife
of a marine reservist they have three
children
her husband chris was killed by a
suicide bomber on
april 8 2019 in bagram afghanistan
the first thing that she said in our
meeting was simply
i'm going to try not to cry
and she told us that before her husband
left on one of his deployments
she sat him down and said god forbid
something happens to you but if it does
where do you want me to bury you
and he told her i don't care
i just want to be near you
and today staff sergeant chris slutman
rests here in arlington
in section 60 alongside
so many of his brothers and sisters in
arms who made the ultimate sacrifice
in action in this longest of american
wars
our gold star and surviving families
wage a fight that goes on long after the
funerals
and it is our sacred duty to do more to
ease the burden at the shoulder
on memorial day and every day
because for as long as america has sent
our sons and daughters into harm's way
those on the home front have also been
on
the front lines and mr president
you know firsthand the pride of seeing a
loved one
put on our country's uniform
you also know what it means to wait and
worry while a son
serves in a battle zone far away
and you know what it means to commit
american troops to fight
and you understand the mixture of pride
and stress
and fear and love that all
our military families live with
as a former commander i know these
feelings myself
for the loved ones of those who have
fallen let me simply say
we know the depth of your sacrifice
but we can never truly know the depth of
your
loss what we can do is honor the memory
of those you lost by caring for those
who mourn them
and by seeking to perfect our union
and defend our democracy
and by striving to live our lives in
ways that advance the ideals
for which they gave their own
it is indeed an honor to be here with
all of you today
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
madam vice president
secretary austin secretary mcdonough
general milley gold star families
my fellow americans
we're gathered at this sacred place
in this solemn hour engage in the most
fundamental of undertakings
the right of remembrance
we remember those who gave their all in
the service of america
in the service of freedom and the
service
of justice remember their sacrifice
their valor
and their grace remember
their smiles their loves
their laughter their essential vibrant
and
transcendent humanity
for while we stand amid monuments of
stone
we must never forget that each of these
markers
for those known and unknown here at
arlington
and far beyond represent
a precious life a son
a daughter a mother a spouse brother a
sister a friend
a neighbor to those
who mourn a loved one today
jill and i have some idea how you're
feeling
our losses are not the same
but that black hole you feel in your
chest it's gonna suck you into it
we get i know the incredible pride
you felt seeing your loved one wear the
uniform of our country
and the pride they felt wearing it
our son beau's service in the delaware
armory national guard unit
the year he spent deployed in iraq
was one of the things that he was most
proud of
in life yesterday marked the anniversary
of his death and it's a hard time
a hard time of year for me
and our family just like it is for so
many of you
it can hurt to remember but the hurt
is how we feel and how we heal
i always feel bo close to me on memorial
day
i know exactly where i need to be
right here honoring our fallen heroes
because through pain and anguish of his
loss
i remember the pride on his face today i
pinned those bars on his shoulders
to all of you who are fighting with the
fresh pain of loss
as hard as it is to believe i promise
you this the day will come
when the image of your loved one will
bring a smile to your lips
before it brings a tear to your eyes
the bible teaches blessed are they that
mourn
for they shall be comforted that comfort
that reassurance can be a long time in
coming
but it will come i promise you
and my prayer for all of you is that
that day will come sooner
rather than later
we all know memorial's day origins lie
in the wake of the civil war
a war for the freedom of all a war for
union
a war for liberty and for the
preservation of the constitution
and calling for such today general john
logan commander of the grand army of the
republic issued
general order number 11. he directed
the nation set aside a day to honor and
i quote those who died in defense of
their country
during the late rebellion and whose
bodies now lie
in almost every city village in hamlet
churchyard throughout the land
and so we have and so we do again today
in our time we're the children
of sacrifice made by a long line of
american service members
each a link in that chain of honor
we live by the light and the flame of
liberty
they kept burning we're free
because they were brave
here on these gentle rolling green hills
and across america and around the globe
lie buried the heroes of the greatest
experiment
the world has ever known
ever seen the experiment bears the noble
name
the united states of america
women and men all those we honor today
gave their lives for their country
but they live forever in our hearts
forever proud forever honorable
forever american
they are they are the sentinels of
liberty
defenders of the downtrodden liberators
of nations
and still today americans
stand watch around the world off of
their great personal peril
war and conflict death and loss
are not relics of our american history
they're part of american story
here in arlington lie heroes who gave
what president lincoln called
the last full measure of devotion
it did not only die at gettysburg or in
flanders field or in the beaches of
normandy
but in the mountains of afghanistan the
deserts of iraq
in the last 20 years
section 60 when i walk through it
reminds me of the cost of war
hundreds of graves hundreds of graves
are here from recent conflicts
hundreds of patriots gave their all
each each of them leaving behind the
family
who live with their pain and their
absence every
single day
i want to assure each of those families
we will
never forget what you gave to our
country
we will never fail to honor
your sacrifice
each day starting when i
was vice president united states i carry
in my pocket
a number of troops killed
during the wars in afghanistan and iraq
not an approximation not rounded off
numbers
they're easily behind an entire
community and family
and today that number is 7036.
7036 fallen angels
who've lost their lives these conflicts
and on this memorial day we honor their
legacy
and their sacrifice duty
honor country
they lived for it they died for it
and we as a nation are eternally
grateful
you know america's been forged in the
basil and the fires of war our freedom
and the freedom of innumerable others
has been secured by young men and women
who answered the call of history
and gave everything in the service of an
idea
the idea of america
it's the greatest idea in the long
history of humankind
an idea that we're all created equal
in the image of almighty god
they were all entitled to dignity as my
father would say and respect
decency and honor love of neighbor
they're not empty words
but the vital beating heart of our
nation
and that democracy must be defended at
all cost where democracy makes
all this possible democracy
that's the soul of america
and i believe it's a soul worth fighting
for and so do you
a soul worth dying for
heroes who lie in eternal
peace in this beautiful place this
sacred place
they believe that too the soul of
america
is animated
by the perennial battle between our
worst instincts
which we've seen of late and are better
angels
between me first and we the people
between greed and generosity
cruelty and kindness captivity and
freedom
the americans of lexington and concord
of new orleans gettysburg the argonne
iwo jima normandy korea and vietnam
afghanistan and iraq and thousands of
places in between
these americans weren't fighting for
dictators
they were fighting for democracy
they weren't fighting to exclude
or to enslave they were fighting to
build and broaden and liberate
they weren't fighting for self they were
fighting for the soul of the nation
for liberty and simple fair play
simple fair play and decency
today as we remember their sacrifice
remind ourselves of our duty to their
memory
to the future they fought for
we owe the honored debt and debt we can
never fully repay
we owe them our whole souls we owe them
our full best efforts to perfect the
union for which they died
we owe them the work of our hands and
our hearts
to make grill the promise of a nation
founded on the proposition that
all of us all of us all of us
are created equal and deserve to be
treated that way throughout our lives
democracy is more than a form of
government
it's a way of being it's a way of seeing
the world
democracy means the rule of the people
the role of the people
not the rule of monarchs not the role of
the money
not the rule of the mighty literally the
rule of the people
the lives of billions from antiquity to
our own hour
have been shaped by the battle between
aspirations of the many and the greed of
the few
between peoples right to
self-determination
and the self-seeking of the dictator
between dreams of democracy
and appetites for autocracy which were
seen around the world
our troops have fought this battle on
fields around the world but also
the battle of our time
and the mission falls to each of us each
and every day democracy itself
is in peril here at home and around the
world
what we do now what we do now
how we honor the memory of the fallen
will determine whether or not democracy
will long endure
we all take it for granted we think we
learn in school you have to every
generation has to fight for it
but look it's the biggest question
whether a system that prizes the
individual
that bends towards liberty it gives
everybody a chance of prosperity
whether that system can and will
prevail against powerful forces that
wish it harm
all that we do in our common life as a
nation is part of that struggle
a struggle for democracy is taking place
around the world democracy and autocracy
a struggle for decency and dignity
just simple decency
a struggle for posterity prosperity and
progress
and yes the struggle for the soul
of america itself
folks you all know it
democracy thrives when the
infrastructure democracy is strong
when people have the right to vote
freely and
fairly and conveniently when a free and
independent press pursues the truth
founded on facts not propaganda
when the rule of law applies equally and
fairly to every citizen
regardless of where they come from what
they look like
excuse me wherever americans are
there there is democracy
churches and synagogues and mosques
neighborhoods and coffee shops and
diners
bleachers at kids baseball or soccer
games
libraries and parks democracy begins and
grows in the open heart
and the impetus to come together for a
common cause
and i might know parenthetically thank
you taps
that's what you do
and that's where it will be preserved
for empathy is the fuel democracy let me
say that again
empathy empathy is the fuel
of democracy our willingness to see each
other
not as enemy as neighbors even when we
disagree to understand
what the other's going through
state the obvious our democracy is
imperfect
it always has been when americans of all
backgrounds races creeds gender
identities
sexual orientations have long spilled
their blood to defend our democracy
the diversity of our country and our
armed and of our armed services
is and always has been an incredible
strength
and generation after generation of
american heroes have signed up to be
part of the fight
because they understand the truth
that lives in every american heart
that liberation opportunity
justice are far more likely to come to
pass in a democracy
than an autocracy
if every person is sacred then every
person
rights are sacred
individual dignity individual worth
individual sanctity the right to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
we say those words so often but think of
it
the right to vote right to rise in a
world as far as
your talent can take you unlimited
by unfair barriers of privilege and
power
such are the principles of democracy
so why would you put these noble
principles into practice how do we do
that
how do we make the idea real
or as close to real as we can make it
this nation was built on an idea the
only nation in the world built on id
every other nation is built on ethnicity
geography
religion etc we were built on an idea
the idea of liberty an opportunity for
all
we've never fully realized that
aspiration of our founding
but every generation has opened the door
a little wider
and every generation is open to wider
and wider
to be more inclusive include those
who've been excluded before
it's a mission handed down generation to
generation
the work of perfecting our union
in 1830 when we were a young nation
this unionist put their sexual interest
ahead of the common good
a great senator daniel webster
rose in the capital to defend the union
to him we're not just a collection of
competing forces
but a coherent hole his cry
first uttered just across the potomac in
the capitol
resonates even now he stood on the floor
and he said liberty and union
now and forever one and inseparable
liberty and union
more than 142 years later
when i first came to the united states
senate at a time when our country was so
deeply divided over vietnam
the struggle of civil rights the fight
of our women's rights
i had the notion that my first task as i
stood to make my first speech on the
floor of the senate
but all of a sudden hit me i'm standing
where daniel webster had stood his desk
was next to mine
i was struck by the weight of history as
corny as it sounds
by the legacy the work we're charged to
carry
forward liberty and union
now and forever
now is then unity is essential to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and so remember those who gave their all
the cause of unity and the cause of a
nation that endures because of
them they must honor their sacrifice
by sustaining the best of america while
honestly confronting all that we must do
to make our nation
fuller freer and more just
we must remember that we may find the
light and the wisdom and yes the courage
to move forward in the words of that
great hymn
fight as they nobly fought of old
when remembrance lies not just our
history but our hope
not just our solemn remembrance but our
renewed purpose
not just our solace but our strength
this memorial day remember that not all
of us
are called to make the ultimate
sacrifice
we all are called by god and by history
and by conscience
to make our nation free and fair
just and strong noble
and whole to this battle
may we now dedicate our souls
that our work may prove worthy of the
blood of our fallen
for this work the work of democracy is
the work of our time
and for all time and if we do our duty
then age ages still to come will look
back on us and say that we
too kept the faith
and there's nothing more important
nothing more sacred
nothing more american than keeping the
faith
and god bless the united states of
america
and may the light perpetually shine upon
the fallen
may god bring comfort to their families
and my god protect our troops
today and always
god bless you all
ladies and gentlemen please stand for
the playing of taps
and remain standing for the benediction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
please receive our closing prayer
lord may we be inspired
by the deep sense of loyalty dedication
and commitment of those we have
remembered today
renew our faith and allegiance to our
nation
and each other lord bless the families
of our fallen
bless our nation's leaders and god
bless america in your loving name i pray
amen
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
place as the official party departs
and for the departure of the state and
territorial flags
um
you
you